the conversations got real it got
pretty gnarly the guys got artistic
i'm gonna let my guard down and i
turned on
crush life under pressure this is your
the bachelorette season 16 episode 8
recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rose
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and i look like a painting
we don't make mistakes we have happy
accidents yes what would we call this
uh monet a da vinci a
man a a marshalls does this look like
some of the generic artwork you can get
at marshalls
it kind of does but i love marshall's tj
maxx and homegoods so cheers to that
and everyone i look like a painting in
part because there was a lot of art
on the bachelorette today what did you
think of this episode
but as much as i love art it can also
tear us apart and this episode
broke my heart because i'm saying
goodbye to bennett
everybody i'll always remember
us this way no he did not get sent home
no there was not even a rose ceremony i
never thought i'd say it but i did turn
on superman
so let's get to it
but before all that happened a real work
of art is here
jojo fletcher everybody just love to
introduce you to jojo who's gonna be
helping me out when i'm gone
yes she has stepped in while chris
harrison stepped away
to take his son to college but neither
of them is neither here nor there
because we're going to a one-on-one
is that i'm looking for a man i can
picture a future with
tasha yes the person of the hour and
perhaps of a lifetime
is zach zach gives this one-on-one with
tasha
where they are gonna take a wedding
photos
zach and i are gonna play dress-up today
we're gonna be shooting our wedding
photos
hello and by the way don't drink for
every time this wedding photographer was
just a character
hello are you gonna be the perfect
how about we make a contour okay let's
change the outfit i'm having too much
fun
grab him on his face and kiss those we
didn't get quite enough of him
but did tasha have quite enough of
taking wedding photos
don't drink for every time tasia seemed
to be dreading
this you ready to put on a wedding dress
um but are you ready yeah
my heart is honestly pounding i can't
believe this is the position i'm in like
are you freaking out right now it's a
little bit yes our girl has talked about
how she
is divorced i mean i've tried on that
wedding dress i've
worn that wedding dress it's held
significance for me
so what did you think of her having to
do this
wedding photo taking one-on-one date it
seemed to me
to understandably be a little triggering
i'm so incredibly nervous she didn't act
out
she didn't freak out and her reaction
was rooted in the reality
that putting on a wedding dress is
significant for her it had real
emotional ties and she talked about that
wedding photos they speak about an
important time she was honest with zach
about her
apprehension are you freaking out right
now just a little bit didn't let it
stand in her way
cheers to mcqueen by the way i've been
thinking about all
the tv queens in my life lately because
i have queen tasha and then
have you guys been watching the crown
the crown
must win yes the crown on netflix the
story of the british royal family
acted out in fiction but rooted in
reality i honestly
tried to watch the first three seasons
and was kind of bored those british
accents can be so soothing they would
just put me right to sleep nothing one
can do about it
one just has to get on with it but i
love everything to do with diana
of course a queen of the people's hearts
and so i just jumped in on season four i
just popped right in
didn't watch the first three knew the
players knew the game and i am loving it
are you guys watching it let me know in
the comments below or should i say
are you watching it let me know in the
comments below oh and there's another
queen in my life the queen's gambit also
on netflix oh and it's about chess so
you think it's gonna be boring but
just like the british people it turns
out it's not boring it's actually quite
interesting it's drama and i loved all
the costumes it's set in another time
and i just found it to be quite escapist
so pour yourself glass of wine watch
that we just love all the queens our
life yes cheers to queens okay
[Music]
queens but back to emotional triggers
now even though this date was a little
tough for taysha it was quite beautiful
for us
wasn't it i loved watching the way that
zach was there for taysha
and i loved watching tasha walk to zack
was he gonna cry oh my god you look
amazing
was i gonna cry
he's so beautiful
so beautiful were you emotionally
touched
let me know in the comments below and i
thought the photos of zach
and tasha looked great are we foreseeing
the future i want to see if this is
like the beginning of true love
but now to the past i was married once
you were yes we've gone back in the
royal line to zach's romantic past
and he just dropped a knowledge bomb on
us turns out zach was also divorced
gosh on this season everyone has lived
you know
we have so many older guys so they have
seen things
and i'm loving it i'm loving uncovering
it what do you think of everyone having
such a past let me know in the comments
below there's nothing wrong with the
past you know we learn from it
has the british royal family learn from
theirs
let me know in the comments below okay i
had fun with you today
it's a great great great day then zach
and tasha go to dinner and he continues
to share all of this information about
his past with her and
wow wow wow zach explained that he had a
brain tumor when he was younger had to
get surgery from it i was like all
dizzy and so i went to this like x-ray
place and i found out
that day that i had a brain tumor so the
next morning i'm like
in surgery and wound up having addiction
issues after going on painkillers he
talked about getting sober
going to rehab everything he went
through with his family and i just
applaud zach for sharing that because
i think so many of us know someone who
has dealt with addiction it's such a
common
issue that people have to face so the
question for me now is just going to be
she's very attracted to how genuine and
down-to-earth he is
but do they have the same interest goals
hopes for the future
what do you think let me know in the
comments below and now from a one-on-one
from the heart to a bunch of guys making
art this is gonna be the third time i'm
getting naked on this
journey it's the group date oh i wish i
had a british accent
don't you let me know in the comments
below today i thought it would be really
really fun
for us to just use our creativity now
the group date
i didn't totally understand i grasped
that it was about art
in many forms what is that yeah exactly
drawing love that you made sure the
nipples were in there nipples are there
play molding it is exactly what you
think it is
puzzles it's a big puzzle needlepoint
i chose the needlepoint okay
best of luck to you yeah lots of
questions for me about like the themes
and the purpose of this date but
whatever the methodology was
the men did open up they shed their
layers
as their clothes oh we're naked for sure
what have i got myself into again yes so
this group date
is about art and we have nudity
again look it is starting to feel like
these producers you know at this point
they'd probably be traveling around the
world
different cultures and lands and
climates would be lending themselves to
the date
but they're just stuck at the la quinta
so we just keep getting naked
this is gonna be the third time i'm
getting naked on this
journey what do you think too much
nudity this season
let me know in the comments below the
royal family
will never i can look the other way
but the men of the bachelorette will so
the guys have to draw
these nude models and you know i will
say this
as much as i'm thinking what the heck
are we doing on this date i did always
want to try one of those
paint and wine nights did anybody ever
do those
it's like you would pay to go drink wine
and paint
not naked people i don't think more of
like a landscape
is it fun let me know in the comments
below so you know we're on kind of like
actually a pretty typical date create a
real world date
except for the naked people and i was a
little disappointed in the skills of the
men because
i was hoping we would have just one
picasso
just a singular da vinci just a little
diamond in the rough of a raphael
but uh no no no dodo don't drink
for all the terrible drawings
i would not buy those even at marshalls
and much like the true life story of the
crown this date keeps taking all kinds
of twists and turns
now we're wearing blindfolds i'm going
to bring out some clay
and some blindfolds and again recycle
reuse here at the laquinta i wondered
were these the same blindfolds
from claire's group date oh and now we
are molding with clay very much the
movie ghost
now just let the clay slide between your
fingers but you know
not the same in ghost they molded a
beautiful vase
and we had patrick swayze here they
molded
spencer snacks i made a pepperoni pizza
and we have blake's penis
it is exactly what you think it is
i'm not making a joke i'm being quite
literal
that's what we got more food noah made
breakfast
so for me this just is a small glimpse
of breakfast in bed every morning with
tasha
we already did that date noah you need
to have a beignet from stratton
bennett molded all the houses he
intended to give to tasha
our new york home our hamptons long
island home
our california home very the crown of
him
windsor castle anyone
and i'm also confused by this rivalry
between bennett
and noah it is apparently building up
and i don't
know why there's some sort of argument i
think about
bennett thinking noah's childish and
noah thinking bennett's privileged
and it came to a head on this date with
noah saying to bennett
is that how you spell privilege i
bennett you spelled privilege p-r-i-v-i
l-e-d-g-e right i'll let you do that one
sounds like a privileged answer
that's not how you spell it so the royal
family would never
how could matters get any worse what
more could possibly go wrong
they very much value education last the
guys were i think
charged with doing a self portrait for
our last exercise
we're gonna do something more personal
self portraits
but it didn't have boundaries it didn't
have to live in a box
no need for a canvas here we got a wood
frame
i'm gonna turn it and leave some room
for someone special someone amazing
a puzzle this last piece says wife kids
and
to a possible future sewing my life
has been challenging and hard the men
really opened up
and i was truly struck by their
vulnerability how much they shared
their raw and unabated emotion oh and
then we're naked again
i'm gonna give this all to you this
physical body and also everything inside
very very naked yes ben wants to give
a literal self-portrait so he comes out
in a robe so this experience
is about taking your walls down and it
is very
literal he gets naked figuratively and
literally
i'm gonna let my guard down this is me
showing up
for you don't worry i'm not naked under
here
the royal family would never
what did you think of ben's
self-portrait let me know in the
comments below
but i did sympathize and because he said
he had feelings he just didn't know how
to express that like i have
things to share but like i've been very
scared
and our queen tasha had feelings and did
express them
you're okay yeah i'm fine i just feel
like it's a lot
she was processing all she'd heard and
she was in tears
saying this is what happens when you
date real
men this is what happens when you start
dating real men
royal applause
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't choose one person i just want to
hang out with all of you
tonight if that's okay we then move to
the nighttime portion of the date where
tasha spends time with all of the guys
they all share even more i appreciate
today
because i don't often get to like be
vulnerable or open
and wow wow wow ben goes into territory
that i don't think we've ever
gone into on the show before he talks
about having an
eating disorder when he was younger i
found out what girls were when i was 15.
i realized they don't like the fat kid
and so
stopped eating started working out all
the time lost like 70 pounds and had
bulimia for 10 years
i don't think we've ever heard a male
contestant discuss that so he let down
his guard he went there
and ben gets the rose ben
would you accept this rose oh and side
note back to our dueling houses of house
bennett and house noah they're still
going at it you know us so tasha tells
them to better figure it out
noah and bennett there's something going
on between you two
and i'm gonna get to the bottom of it
one way or another whose side are you
on here bennett or noah's inform me in
an eloquent
manner in the comments below
but from art to the scary nighttime dark
easy gets a spooky one-on-one
the night is the night of my 101. yes
easy gets
a scary date and he prepares for it by
doing high knees what was this tonight
is the night of my 101. all right so
easy is preparing for his one-on-one
date and
i scared you guys did i scare you
let me know in the comments below
oh i love a good scare and tasia started
her date with easy
in an uneasy way she scared him
and oh now we are told easy and tasha's
date
is going to involve ghosties i thought
it'd be super fun for us to go ghost
hunting
okay is that cool i'm down for that
were you there tell the truth
you were there weren't you i love it
they are going around
the laquinta resort and spa and they
even have a map to where the ghosties
are oh is this a map oh my gosh this is
a map
did you make them the map you did
i love it prepare yourself prepare
yourself now
prepare yourself what did you guys think
of this date i thought it was fun
don't drink for every time they got
scared by a ghostly noise that was very
clearly piped in by the producers for
dramatic effects
or was it real
at one point deja was so scared she just
peaced out
but what i loved was easy followed her
with the wine
good job easy let me tell you something
about love right so like when you're in
love
you both are in it so like if you scream
i scream
oh and apparently easy will follow her
anywhere because at dinner
he tells her he is falling in love with
her
i honestly feel like i'm falling in love
with you what did you guys think
was it too soon i thought it was too
soon we haven't seen easy and tasha
interact that much and i was a little
bit
taken aback by that you're a solid good
man
but tasha compliments him and she leans
in and then she pulls away and i'm
scared
unfortunately i can't give you this rose
yes in a decision that i thought was
shockingly easy
tasha says goodbye i'm sorry easy
is it okay if i walk you out yeah were
you shocked scared surprised
let me know in the comments below the
royal family
never shows fear sorry okay even easy
said tasha
is this real are you sure tasha this is
real
yeah gosh so easy is gone and you know
so much has happened
this season that i kind of forgot about
two on ones
and yes it's coming down to a
gentleman's
duel a tet attempt a mono
a mono noah versus
bennett or die
you're the best man win we'll see so
bennett and noah are meeting for this
two on one and bennett says he has a
gift for noah i've been a peacemaker all
my life and he says it is a friendship
gift i'll start with
a friendship gift and what did you guys
think i wasn't sure about it
there was a red bandana for the blood of
their battles
it's red because i hope there's no bad
blood for us and
mustached socks for noah's tortured path
the only place that you should wear a
mustache is on your feet
and a novel on emotional intelligence
for
bennett's place in our bachelor history
books this book will be really really
helpful
these are tools that any woman is going
to want to have
in a husband and a father like what
was that what did you think of bennett's
gift to noah
he said it was a friendship gift to
teach noah
that he wasn't ridiculing him and i'm
not
trying to belittle you i'm literally
trying to love you up
i hate to say it but i thought it was
ridiculous
i have turned on
bennett exquisite selfishness
of your motives and the final item we
shall pull out of our box will be
bennett's robe i thought it was the
trophy of the evening
yes i can no longer wear the robe
the tartan the crest of the bennett
family i still love robes though i want
to make that clear still a big fan of
ropes
are you a house divided on bennett
cast your vote on this urgent matter in
the comments below
okay you guys are not shutting bennett
out can't wait to watch him in paradise
but i mean i did think about it a little
differently after this episode let me
know in the comments below
also why didn't know i have a mustache
during all this didn't he shave it off
did it just grow back how fast does
mom's facial hair
grow oh but we are left on a to be
continued
next week on the bachelorette bonnie
what's in the box what's in the box
um oh what's in the box and additionally
with tears you bring that into the
equation that makes it really real
will we turn on zach next every time i
talk to him
i uncover something that i'm just like
hold on a second
[Music]
what did you all think of this episode i
really enjoyed it from
our fallen king to our rising queen
to our possible prince let me know in
the comments below as always if you guys
want to connect with me more i am
on twitter tick tock instagram and cameo
at laurenzema you can get a personal
message from me on cameo
and unlike the fairly cold british
family
what does one have to do to get some
kindness in this family
i love you so much thanks for watching
and we will be back next week
bye
i'm in the box
[Music]
you